you'd be shocked to learn how much the
disney live-action remakes rely on cgi
to bring the worlds to life the cgi is
impressive
but seeing what the films look like
without the finishing touches show just
how creative the minds of the artists
working on the projects are
which film had only one actual live
action scene
what was the trick to achieving the
realistic looking wings in maleficent
well well is there anything more
exciting than watching maleficent whip
and soar through the sky effortlessly
while we saw the picture-perfect final
product the reality is
bringing this gravity-defying magic was
anything but
effortless let's break it down wires and
large prongs to hold the performers up
to start
add some stunt people in all blue to
maneuver and manipulate the large prongs
and then it's time for cgi to do its
magic
as we can see here the outfit and all of
her surroundings are cgi'd in
and do an incredible job at really
bringing the fantasy to life
while angelina jolie looks so poised and
effortless performing
let's take a second to check out her
unbelievable backup
all the blue bodies moving about now
that
is a group effort so how about the wings
notice those little velcro stubs on
their backs those are the marks for the
giant cgi wings that were eventually
added
definitely more impressive some of the
performers who wore the wings wore
weighted backpacks built specifically
for the performers that allowed them to
feel what the cgi wings would be
depicting in terms of weight and size
allowing the flying to look incredibly
realistic this is pretty much as close
to real wings as one can get
stop doing that when it comes to gravity
defying scenes
disney has it all figured out remember
the large
prong-like tools used to help maleficent
fly the same technology alongside wires
was used in the milan film
providing the production with a whole
host of exciting possibilities
for example when they needed to be
running up walls all they had to do was
rig up the performers
shoot the scenes and then voila cgi
magic took care of the rest of the world
that needed to be created
how about those bunnies hopping
alongside mulan as she runs through a
field
in reality mulan was running solo her
cgi friend's only being added afterwards
same goes for this chicken when it comes
to the environments we were shocked to
see
how much cgi contributed from the large
buildings or natural settings to all of
the small details of the settings
check out these epic scenes don't have
any large sandy mountains
oh no problem we've got cgi for that
you smell that
so we all know that there was definitely
cgi used to bring the live-action remake
of beauty and the beast since
dan stevens is anything but a beast
we have to admit we're pretty impressed
with emma watson's acting
we never would have guessed this is what
she would see acting opposite her
stevens didn't just wear any motion
capture suit but a special poofy one
built out to give the shape and
structure of the beast stevens had
double the work when it came to motion
capture though
he was required to recreate his
performances in a studio doing
specifically
facial motion capture for the editors to
work within the creation of the beast's
face
how about these very animated inanimate
object
naturally lumiere was created with cgi
for the scenes where the magical
characters of the palace were true to
their actual size
puppets and animatronic creations were
used in place and then edited after the
fact with cgi
making them incredibly lifelike why is
that not a surprise
i'm sorry it's no surprise this live
action flick had a lot of cgi
contributed to the final cut
there is a magic carpet soaring through
the sky after all
so how did they make it all happen well
the carpet in reality looks a bit more
like a double mattress and is set on a
platform that moves around for the
actors to perform on
get the right shot add the cgi and voila
carpet magic now aladdin is very nimble
and
probably the original parkour star
there's no denying that
but luckily he wasn't really jumping
from precarious lava surrounded pieces
of rock
though his moves in the studio are still
really impressive
as for the genie well that's all cgi
no really will smith's blue genie was
literally
entirely cgi he had to do a lot of
motion capture and on set he was pretty
easy to spot in this
highly detailed grey leotard not so
magical
as it is but with the added visual
effects it's breathtaking
still blue hollywood movie magic knows
how to bring fantasy to the screen
pretty expertly
and it shows in the live-action remake
of alice in wonderland
mia wasikowska had her work cut out for
her she was the only real human in some
scenes in the film
meaning she was performing opposite
voice actors and both people on the set
in green suits and separately marked eye
lines
not only that but her entire fight scene
with the jabberwocky was performed on
her own in the studio
with the rest of the magic added later
she pulls it off
pretty flawlessly of course it's not
alice in wonderland without a bunch of
size shifting
the amount in the film is extensive
notice how they turned many of the
characters into animations
until blending everything into one world
then of course
the famous falling down the tunnel scene
the process to create this was
anything but simple and the results very
impressive
it's absolutely alex you're absolutely
alice i'd know you anywhere
what is cinderella without a beautiful
carriage unfortunately
cinderella didn't really get to ride in
the carriage but the horses
those were real we were shocked to learn
that the entire palace setting was
entirely computer generated
talk about details and speaking of
details
how about these perfectly designed mice
you can see each strand of hair and
every whisker
and of course we needed to see a bit of
bippity boppity boo thank you cgi
yes the spirit of christmas
is definitely found in the nutcracker in
the four realms
this opening scene makes us feel like
it's the holiday season
and guess what from the snow to the cars
it's all cgi one of the most interesting
characters in the film was the teacup
man
look at how they used illustrations to
create this fantastical image
and speaking of beautiful images we
can't get over this intricate set
however without cgi it's mostly an empty
room aside from a few prop gears
are you ready ready the live action lion
king actually
only had one true live action shot
since all the characters are animals
naturally they had to be created by cgi
though the process to make them appear
so realistic is impressively extensive
building out from a sketch and adding
all the elements needed like muscles and
fur
seriously while the lion king featured a
complete cast of cgi characters
jungle book had one human being acting
opposite an ensemble of cgi creations
we were fascinated to see how they
created the image of little mowgli
riding a tiger
the trick two humans hand stilts
some padding and the color blue
sometimes the equipment doesn't have to
be so high tech though
this film was an array of approaches
from puppets to stilts to shadows
what are you doing so deep in the jungle
mary poppins is the queen of making
ordinary things extraordinary
and the film mary poppins returns does
the same there is a blend of both
cutting-edge cgi and old-fashioned
cartoons
the difference between this huge dance
sequence with
and without cgi is mind-boggling the
film also paid special tribute to the
original mary poppins film with the
addition of the beloved cartoon penguins
bringing those sweet characters back to
life can you
imagine that it really is incredible to
see how advanced and sophisticated the
cgi technology used is
especially considering what cgi used to
look like
we can't wait to see the creation of the
new cruella film
now while we're big fans of the
realistic creations featured in the
films
we'll also always have a soft spot for
the mary poppins penguins
you